well i'm obviously uh very pleased for
all those who've had this hanging over
them for a long time um because it's
been very difficult for a number of
people uh and i'm extremely pleased that
uh we've got the outcome and the verdict
that's been declared um so it's good
news as far as the army is concerned do
you think it should ever have been
allowed to get this far
well it's not really for me to judge i
mean what i would say is the head of the
army is that um you know we have values
and standards that must be upheld and of
course we need to make sure that um we
do that and sometimes if things have to
investigate they have to be investigated
and how that happens is another matter
what do you think was the scale of
misbehavior by british troops towards
prisoners in the afghan and the iraq
conflicts
well i think
much has been reported we've learned
lessons from things and bar musa is on
the record
and the british army absolutely espouses
um ethical standards of behavior and the
effect of all of that has been that you
know we've learned lessons and we've
studied our doctrine and we train and
teach people
in a much more up-to-date way perhaps
than we might have done 20 or 30 years
ago do you think there's a different
ethos in the british military compared
to the americans
um i can't really comment uh to be
honest uh all i can really do is to
comment from a british perspective and
we have very clearly understood values
and standards um and ethical behavior is
right at the heart of everything that we
aspires
so so in a conflict when your
comrades are being injured and killed
how should you treat uh prisoners or
people that you wish to interrogate how
far can you go in expressing your
feelings or indeed trying to get out
information from them
well i think i think the important thing
is that um
that you retain the moral high ground
and everything that um we try and do in
the british army is is to lead with that
in mind
and i think that's really the measure
that one must be
gauged by